The first thing I want to say is, if you are dealing with a depressed person, he is very depressed
You should try giving him antidepressants.
Because if he dies, you can not help him
Well, if you suffer, you're bound by some kind of thing
Hold on to any rope someone throws to you.
One of the things that I do with my clients (patients) all the time and especially if they are in trouble, is to tell them
Look, "I do not know exactly what will help you"
But do not throw away any possibility, because you may not have this luxury. "
Antidepressants have helped many people, and there are technical reasons why.
...So
This is a simple answer, which is not related to what I described earlier
So, if you are offered a gift by your community, and effective
Try it. Do not care about your assumptions.
Away from that ....
In a lot of time you see people suffering from depression, for example
There are multiple reasons, but I will take a common reason.
You can think of it in association with the story of Peter Mann,
(Peter Mann) is a person who does not want to mature. True?
Now, the problem with Peter Mann is that he can become king, but a king on the island of Neverland, and Neverland is unproductive.
So being king on nothing is unhelpful
One of the things you see a lot in people with depression.
(And I do not blindly explain the causes of depression, because there are many of them)
People who do not have an adequate system in their lives often feel overwhelmed.
For example, if someone comes to see me, he says he is depressed
They always ask their usual questions.
"do you have a job?"
If you do not have a job, you are really in trouble in our society.
First, your biological balances tend to drift
Because there is no reason to sleep at a specific time, and there is no reason to wake up.
And for many people, if they do not wake up at the usual time,
They dilute their vital rhythmic balance, which is enough to make them depressed immediately.
Especially if he falls asleep at noon.
They also do not have a goal, and people are not good without a goal
This is not a hypothesis.
We understand circuits that control positive emotions.
We know how to work, almost all the positive emotions you will tell.
It will not be the result of collecting things.
The result of seeing things will be working as you move toward a goal you evaluate.
This is completely different and you need to know it.
Because people are often obsessed with, for example, finishing doctoral dissertations
Their preconceived assumption is that they will rejoice for a month.
And often instead they are depressed: and they think
Hell, I've been working on it for 7 years, and what am I doing now?
And that makes them depressed, is the question "What do I do now ?:
They are fine if they enjoy the goal,
It has always been useful, they get a lot of fun and enthusiasm.
For this is how our nervous system works.
Most of your positive emotions occur during your pursuit of a goal.
If you take drugs, such as cocaine or steroids, cause it's fun
Is because they do systems that enable you to continue the goal
This is why people love her
So if you do not have a job, you do not have a structure.
This is not good, too, tend not to possess too much.
So you are overwhelmed by chaos and lack of foundation, and you do not have positive emotions.
2) Well, do you have any friends
So, sometimes you see depressed people: they have no job, no friends,
They do not have social relations,
They have an additional health problem, and they have alcohol and drugs.
My experience was: If you have three of these problems,
Almost impossible to help you
You are so steeped in anarchy that you can not go out,
Because it is advancing on one side, and one of these problems is being dealt down.
So one of the things he told depressed people: she
Do not sacrifice my stability, get a job.
Even if you do not have exactly the job you want, get a job for a sample, you need a job.
Get some friends, get into the dating circle.
See if you can establish an intimate relationship
Establish some of the basic things that are like columns to be based on your life.
Well, that's a practical thing.
This is one example of depression.
Well 'the destination is that you do not throw them at them.
You must negotiate with the person.
You also have to teach them to negotiate with themselves, and this is useful for their knowledge.
And you can overwhelm yourself to do things, but I do not advise you.
The one who advised him is to ask yourself what you are willing to do
It's an effective technique, it's like meditation, for example
You can wake up in the morning and you can think
I want to have a good day 'so I want to go to sleep without feeling guilty.
Because, you know I did not do some of the things that I said I would do,
And I want to get an exciting day.
So I have to spend my responsibilities, and I want to enjoy the day as well.
Then you can ask yourself, OK
What should I do, to get it, which I have the willingness to do
And you are likely to have done it for 3 or 4 days, your brain will come back and tell you what to do.
So you will say that there is a homework that did not end for three weeks,
Should you finish it quickly, it will take you 10 minutes
And you know, you avoided and tortured yourself to death, to extend 72 hours continuous
And if you're done here, there's something else you can do.
And you know ... and this is a small obligation that you can get rid of too
So what you do in this situation is to teach the person to negotiate with himself.
Well: Let's try to define your goals, because you must have goals, which are these goals
You may say "I'm so depressed that I do not have goals"
I say to them, "Choose the least goals that conflict
And act accordingly and see what happens "
Because sometimes your emotional systems are corrupt
So much so that you have to pretend ... to act before you begin to ratify
I mean, people assume they should ratify and then act, but that
Sometimes this is true, and many times is incorrect.
So the trick, if you treat someone and work with him
And help him establish a structure, is to discover what he will do
Now if he wants to improve his condition, and this is not supposed,
Because there are often benefits for not improving
These benefits in order to be a martyr
Or perhaps the benefits of doing what your sick family wants to do
Because they actually want you to fail.
Assuming you want to improve, there is usually something you can know,
To contribute towards a steady goal.
The default is essentially behavioral assumption, is
Small gains that are repeated, are super-powerful
So, this is another thing you should know about your life
Is something learned by a molecule of reading (The Quadrant Solzhenition)
He was a Russian philosopher and novelist
He said: You can look at your life, and you can see the imbalance in it
I mean all you have to do is look.
And can begin to reform
By noting what you can actually fix.
You know, sometimes people try to fix things they can not fix, I do not recommend you.
Because if you try to fix something that you can not fix, you will destroy it.
For example, you can find all kinds of university graduates, and they are ready
To restructure the global economic system
They can not keep their room clean
There is a big gap, and it's amazing that people do not notice it.
So if you focus your attention, you can see things you can fix.
These things scream at you, they do it really, and we know how it happens.
Let me give you an example, because the rooms are full of stories.
Stories have an impact on you, this is a classic example.
Take two groups of university students, put them in a lab,
One group gives multiple test questions,
There are words associated with old age
The other group gives the same choice
But the words are associated with the young
This independent of context, experience, is only a characterization.
And then measure the speed of university students as they walk to the elevator
Who completed the test
Which contained words associated with aging, walked slowly to the elevator
They do not know they're doing it
This study was re-tested more than once in different formats
You are incredibly sensitive to the stories you tell your environment
Because your environment is not made up of objects
This is wrong, your environment is made up of something like tools and consequences.
You are a user object for the tool, you are an aware object
things that
For example, if I took something from the room and said, well what was in the room?
Would not say like, random patterns in carpet.
But it is a fact like any other purpose.
You will say "chairs" because you can sit on them
And will say "railing" because you can use,
You will say "drawer" because you can walk it.
This is what you see this is what you interact with
And if you pay attention to your environment.
You are an extended idea, and all your experiences are you
It will tell you what to do all the time, and all you have to do is do it
But then you have to decide if you want to do it.
One of the things I noticed in people ....
When I started to study these legends and stories,
And I got the idea about the fact that life can be meaningful enough to justify its suffering
I thought it was a great idea
Because it's not exactly optimistic, you know, some people will tell you to be happy
These people are stupid, I tell you these people are stupid!
There will be things that come and crush you so hard you can not believe them.
And then you will not be happy, so if life is for happiness
In those situations what do you do? Why do you live?
But life is not to be happy if you are happy you are so lucky, you should enjoy it
You must, for it is the grace of God, so to speak
As for the meaning, I thought well
People know when to do something meaningful, they can know that
So why the hell do not they do meaningful things all the time?
It seems obvious, you can do it, I mean it's tough
You know, because others want you to do other things, it's hard
But everything is difficult
I thought "Well, I understand why" it took me about 10 years to understand
People have a choice!
Check # 1: Nothing you do mean anything
Well that's tired, healthy
The nihilism of life and all existential concern, you know, that kind of pain
But the beneficial side is "nothing you do makes sense"
Is that you do not have to do anything, you have no responsibility!
Now you will suffer because things are meaningless
But this is a small cost to be totally useless!
Alternative .... is (check # 2) "Everything you do has importance"
Oh really! If you make a mistake it is a real mistake!
If someone is betrayed, the world tends little to evil, instead of good
What you do has importance!
Well if you believe it, you can have a meaningful life, but there is no disrespect
That means responsibility, which means that the decisions you make are important
That means when you do something wrong it is wrong!
Well ... do you want it?